that's zendaya and tom holland out and
about in london over the weekend it's
just the beginning of this really
adorable
romance that we're watching kind of
bloom on camera here's the couple
walking side by side outside his family
home tom carried a mug while zendaya
cuddled up with her boyfriend during the
stroll while they may have dressed
casual there's nothing low-key about
this car in this pick the couple is seen
getting into tom's porsche i just feel
very lucky this comes amid spider-man no
way home's record-breaking numbers at
the box office i honestly feel a little
bit numb at the premiere zendaya stopped
tom in his tracks while chatting with
e.t how are you feeling about that and
tackling that they're losing things i
think zendaya just sounds like they're
just showed up and this couple's love
story has been a journey i am sweating
dating rumors first began in the summer
of 2017 amid the actors worldwide press
tour for spider-man homecoming have you
found that it's hard to date in
hollywood so it's such a young age of
course it is i mean it's hard to say at
any age i mean it doesn't matter you
know where you are either i mean it's
just hard to say in general you know but
zendaya shut down speculation at the
time when she simply called tom one of
her best friends and a great dude and
that august zendaya told e.t she wasn't
phased by their romance rumors i mean it
happens all the time and of course you
know we we expected it i mean it's it's
um
it comes with the territory it comes
with the job so it's all good cut to
2021 the couple was seen packing on the
pda around los angeles i'm excited we're
going to have a good press tour i think
zendaya gave e.t her reaction to the
massive fan response to their romance
those pictures of you and tom and people
were so excited because they're like
spiderman mj it's real like it was like
the world was rooting for this moment
well i'm excited for the film to come
out i can't wait for everybody to see um
spiderman when it does come out and you
know we we all work so hard we're all so
you know we're all so close from that i
just thought it was cool because people
were actually rooting they were you know
look the internet can be a cynical place
and it was overall joy it seemed when
those pictures came out well thank you
in november holland officially confirmed
the relationship to gq
[Music]
and will the couple work together
outside of the marvel universe i don't
know i don't know how excited people
would be to just jump on board while
chatting with et about season two of
euphoria zendaya joked how tom could
land a cameo in the hit hbo series your
boy tom holland said he would love a
cameo i mean what does he have to do to
show up for season three listen we
talked about it you know because uh
um he supported me through the whole the
whole season and you know we we joke
about like just fitting him into the
background
it was an easter egg see if someone can
can spot him
[Music]